ald brothers and
sisters my respected shaks and and
Scholars I greet you all with the
greetings of peace with the greetings of
the people of paradise asalamu
alayum it is an honor for me and I
believe it is an honor for everyone of
you to be present at this
Gathering not only to say things and to
hear
things but to
benefit from the sake of this Gathering
to to benefit from the blessings of this
Gathering I think this is much better
than what we have to say and what you
have to
listen and may Allah subhana
inshallah bring to our hearts and our
minds and our
families these blessings these baras and
may these blessings be continuous
blessings in
I am again honored to to be next
to Allah subhana tala reward him and it
is really a blessing for all of you to
have him in this community
here it is masallah a great blessing so
may Allah make you benefit and also make
us benefit from far away over there in
in Phoenix but we're not too
far so brothers and sisters I have
decided with a permission from both of
the
sh I've decided to talk about a verse
where Allah subhana wa tala in the Quran
says it means Allah
was not going to punish them while you
are with
them again Allah is not going to punish
them while you remain with them while
you are a part of them a part of that
Society this is indeed a very beautiful
verse and it
requires a
contemplation I want to talk to you a
little bit about the time when Prophet
sallallahu alaihi wasallam came to this
world how was the world back in those
days according to
abass the famous Indian scholar he talks
about the Persian Empire he talks about
the bantine Empire he talks about the
condition in the Arab
world
in a book called Islam and the
world so he talks overall he talks about
what did the world
lose because of the weakening of the
Muslims what has the world lost the
Christians Jews Hindus people of other
faiths because of the weakness of the
Muslims so he goes into details about
this topic but overall at the beginning
of the book he talks about the
conditions of these empires of these
societies before our beloved Prophet
Muhammad s alai came into Mecca and
Medina bantine Empire was in a great
catastrophe why because there was a lot
of
Oppression Emperors showed a lot of
Oppression to the people there
then you had the Persian
Empire the Emperors believe that they
come from holy blood from a Divine
blood and because of that they are
Divine
people and they would make other average
human beings to worship them and the
average human being had to consider the
Emperor as God or had to consider all of
those Royals from the emperor's family
or the King's family had to consider
them as Divine
people so you see a great difference
racial difference between the rulers and
the average human
beings now let's take a look at their
social
problems the royal
families they did this but also average
families in the
society they would get married the
father with his own
daughter the brother with his own
sister this was normal had there was no
problem especially within the royal
families why because they wanted to
preserve the wealth and they wanted to
preserve their Kingdom or the
Empire these were social illnesses that
existed back in those
days to keep their blood pure to keep
their Divine blood and then we go to and
I'm not going to stop a lot and go into
into into their problems but I just want
to make you think about these problems
back in the
days and you yourself can connect with
the problems of the 21st
century you can do your own you can do a
connection between those problems with
today's
problems there were slaves back in the
days and we really dislike the slavery
but what about nowadays we have modern
slaves today we have modern
slaves each American has 34 slaves
around the
world so you you can do calculations and
you can can watch there are so many
programs I have no time to go all over
those details but I want you to be able
to what I'm saying right now to connect
the present with the past and I want you
to recognize and to realize that the
coming of prophet sallallahu alaih
wasallam was important for the world and
it served the purpose and really was a
messenger of God proven to be a
messenger of God not just by words but
with
facts so the
Hindus they believed also that they were
divine and everybody else was their
servant in India
Hindus they believed that they are
Divine and everybody else is their
servant they had to serve these Divine
leading
families politically you know the
leading whether they were kingdoms or
just other types of governments they
considered themselves as I said again
Divine
people look at the Arab Society or think
about that before Prophet sallallahu
alaihi wasallam came there what were
their problems major problems little
child was nothing to them the the the
girl the Quran says she is going to be
asked on the day of judgment what was
her sin what was the reason that she was
killed this was a society
disease nowadays they kill the children
in the hospitals every single
day true
abortion so it's going to be asked why
what was her sin because she was not
able to because she because the
family was not able to afford we are the
ones who give you and we are the ones
who provide for them as well there's no
reason for you to go and kill the
children again Society disease what else
a woman a woman would go with so many
people as a matter of fact there's
of she talks about four types of
marriages and amongst these types of
marriages he mentions and says that a
woman would go with so many men
and then if she had a child with this
man she would point the finger at one of
these man and would say you are my
husband and the man had to accept that
this is how the tradition was back in
the
days if we talk about alcohol and
gambling this was a major disease in
that Society
too Arabs were known for their
poetry and if you take a look at the sh
The Poetry that used to be written
during the days of the J during the days
of the ignorance you will find a lot of
poetry talking about alcohol as a matter
of fact alcohol was the main theme of
their
poems alcohol the beauty of alcohol the
beauty of being drunk and so on and so
on when Prophet sallallah alaihi
wasallam came up with a revelation from
God the companions they say that we saw
the wine on the streets of Medina like
Rivers flowing on the
streets we heard that and we obey
that something bad Society disease get
rid of
it now what else they
were known
for their extremities in
gambling nowaday
Society take a look at the average
Americans and even Muslims there's a lot
of
Muslims they can't stop
gambling I know people they go in Vegas
they go in Vegas at the end of their
week instead of spending time with their
family and children they go and they
play over their m Muslims
gambling yeah we know we don't win
anything but just to kill the time like
they have a lot to
live Subhan Allah the time can be can be
used in different ways not to kill the
time to go to gamble in in
Vegas so it is a disease it is a disease
but look in what extent they went back
in the
days if they had no more money to to
spend on
gambling they would put their own
families including children and their
own
houses when they would gamble so the
weth finished then next step is putting
the money I mean putting the house their
own wives and their own children take it
it's
yours this is oppression this is real
this is the real face of Oppression
social
oppression
Prophet sallallahu alaihi wasallam came
with a Divine message brothers and
sisters even average Americans nowadays
they are able to
recognize the benefits of
Islam when I see a lot of them I talk to
them and I start talking about the
problems with the media you know how the
how the how the media portrays the
Muslims nowadays they so we know that a
lot lot of them they so we know
that we know that this is not the true
thing we know that they they're trying
to make the money they have their own
benefit in
this
so we have to as Muslims though we have
to
recognize that Allah subhah wa ta'ala
has sent the messenger of
God as a true Mercy for for this
world by the way Prophet Muhammad peace
be upon him was not a mercy only for one
kind of the world he was not Mercy only
for the man he was not Mercy only for
his close friends he was not Mercy only
for the Arabs but he was Mercy for
non-arabs he was Mercy for women he was
Mercy for children he was Mercy even for
little for
animals
the man who saved a dog or a woman who
saved the cat earned the paradise